hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the groundwork
for the metaphysics of morals Kant gives
you several different formulations of
this main principle that he uses called
the categorical imperative and the
second formulation of the categorical
imperative we have right here on the
board act in such a way that you always
treat humanity while they're in your own
person or in the person of another never
simply as a means but always at the same
time as an adze and that's quite a
mouthful so you know what exactly does
that that mean as a principle if you
wanted to really boil it down and this
is a you know perhaps a little bit of
oversimplification here so I want to
caution against against taking this to
be the single way to do it but if you
really wanted to boil it down into a
nice easy thing to remember would be
don't use people but you'd have to
remember don't use yourself as well as
using other people and you also have to
clarify what it means to use people in
these sort of circumstances what it
means to treat another person as a
object of use so what we're gonna do in
this short video is look at the wake hot
get
there and then what this actually means
and how you would apply it but we're not
going to look at specific examples not
the examples that Kant uses or other
examples because I'm going to do that in
some other core concept videos dealing
with this the second formulation of the
categorical imperative so before we get
to this formulation cons going to go
through a couple of important steps
along the way and it may look like just
window dressing but I think that if you
actually do follow along with it you'll
get something out of it you know the
better understanding of exactly what he
means by this this principle so he
starts off by saying the will is
conceived as a power of determining
oneself to a action in accordance with
the idea of certain laws now this is a
pretty typical way of looking at things
the will is a capacity or power of
determining oneself to action the will
is the Faculty of choice it's what we
use to choose what we want to do but we
don't want to do what we want to be how
we want to do things how we want to be
all these sorts of things what kind of
relationships we want to have the rules
are all a matter of will and we can do
this in accordance with laws meaning we
can do this in accordance not with
necessarily laws like you know the
positive legal sense of you know
speeding or not speeding or filling out
your taxes properly or stuff like that
well that would fit in there and not in
the sense just of natural laws like if I
you know drop the chalk the track is
going to fall because gravity pulls it
down word and you know grab the operates
according to certain physical laws as
well what he means are were able to give
ourselves rules and and law is a rule
but it's not just any kind of rule it's
a rule that's supposed to apply
universally or objectively to to all
beings of a certain sort so we're
thinking in terms of humanity we're
thinking in terms of rational beings so
he says this kind of power to be able to
choose to act to
to make oneself do things in accordance
with laws that was only fun rational
beings now how does this work so he says
what serves the will is a subjective
ground of its self-determination is an
end so what does he mean there so a
subjective ground of self-determination
when I choose something I'm a subject
and what it when I'm using to ground my
choice is the thing that I'm trying to
achieve attain produce the effect that I
would like to to occur right through my
action so I want to make my wife happy I
sing her a song or give her a kiss or
you know buy her flower or something
like that that's an action the goal of
the action is the end that's what Kahn
is calling a subjective ground here and
I says if it is given by reason alone it
must be equally valid for all rational
beings so if it's not just a matter of
my subjective preferences or my personal
history but it's given by reason alone
that's kind of hard to find things that
are given by reason alone there's not an
awful lot of them out there
in existence so you know buying my rifle
flowers not going to be given by reason
alone that you know but say while I'm in
a marriage I ought to in fact assure
that my spouse be happy in that
relationship with me I think we could
attain to that by by reason conte
doesn't spend a lot of time on those
three things but we could we could work
our way through those those would be
equally valid for all rational beings
now he says what on the other hand
contains merely the ground of the
possibility of an action whose effect is
an end has called them means so we have
here the relationship between means and
ends you know again he's being very
technical what is he saying what
contains merely the ground of the
possibility of an action whose effect is
an end what what gives you how you get
from point A to point B point a being
where you are point B being what you're
trying to get to
that's a means that's an
other way of thinking about so he says
we can now we look at this in two
different ways the subjective ground of
a desire is an impulsion the objective
ground of abolitionism motive and we
have a distinction between subjective
ends which are based on impulses you
know for example if I have if I have an
itch right oh you know my my heart my
elbow itches and I start to scratch it
could be that relieving the the
discomfort of an itch is my end and the
means is they actually taking my my hand
and you know rubbing it in a certain way
now if my elbow itches that doesn't mean
all human beings elbows itch at this
moment in time that's a very subjective
and you know relieving this particular
thing there's a lot of things along
those lines where if we think about them
their subjective ends for us and they
may be very important for us but they
are still merely subjective ends they
don't go for for everybody right no he
talks about objective ends so some ends
are objective and those are valid for
every rational being so he says
practical principles are formal if they
abstract from all subjective ends their
material if they're based on subjective
ends and and subjective certain
impulsion so this further distinction
between the practical and material you
know the things that concern us as
individuals and not as rational beings
in a you know sort of matrix with all
other rational beings those are merely
material and those cannot guide our will
in terms of moral action oh well you
know they're good for us but they're not
good per se
so he says ends did a rational being so
it's you and me we're both rational
beings adopts arbitrarily as an effects
of his action material ends those are
merely subjective those are only
relative it's only their relation to
special characteristics and the subjects
power of a petition which gives them
their values so yeah again very
technical terminology what is caught me
well you know you have those desires or
you have those inclination I have these
inclinations and desires and satisfying
those is an end for me but it's not an
end for everybody so you know a for
instance I like this this particular tie
and I've been told that it's not really
that stylish anymore apparently at one
time it was but I like wearing this so
I'm gonna wear it right it pleases my
eye and it may not please other people
putting this tie on is satisfying some
subjective end of me that doesn't mean
that all people need to wear ties or
even all people when they're shooting
you know
lecture videos need to wear ties or
anything like that it's not a it's not
an objective thing in that sense it's
very subjective it's relative now Hawk
goes on from this he says suppose there
were something whose existence has in
itself an absolute value not a merely
relative value let's pause for a second
think about this what does it mean for
something to have a relative value it
will satisfy certain desires or
inclinations that I have so reading
Shakespeare for example I've got some
Shakespeare on the Shelf reading
Shakespeare is a great thing it's
wonderful I I personally would love to
see a world in which everybody could
have the opportunity to read and to
appreciate and even you know maybe even
study Shakespeare with somebody who
really knows what they're doing which by
the way is not me when it comes to
Shakespeare but I have to grant that
that volumes of Shakespeare at least
from a Content perspective do not have
some sort of absolute value in
themselves they're valuable as a means
to certain ends we can take them as and
so you know the house starts on fire I
would very likely grab that you know the
two volumes set of the collected works
of William Shakespeare in opposition to
some of the other books
maybe there's other stuff in here that I
should grab first the volumes of books
that has greater worth right that
greater value is ends but it's merely
limited now is there anything that has
an absolute value according to Conte
there is according to Conte is not just
a matter the way some philosophers think
everything just having a relative value
for one person for another person he
says there is something that actually
has absolute value so what is that he
says this is something which as an end
in itself could be a ground of
determinants laws that would be the
ground of a possible categorical
imperative so what would that be he says
man or humanity and in general every
rational being exists as an end in
itself there's a lot more here but let's
pause over that and just repeat that for
a second think about that every human
being even the most depraved even the
the you know most foolish the most
stupid the most obstinate every human
being by virtue of being a human being
exists as an end in itself something of
absolute value that is a really radical
startling thought how does the only
person who's thought that - by the way
being plenty of other people thought
that before him but the count is really
exploring this in a certain way so he
says this would this is this has value
human being his value is an end in
itself not merely as a means for
arbitrary use now is that to say that
human beings can't be used by other
human beings no there's a matter of fact
that's precisely what Kant is getting
after we are vulnerable to being used by
human beings we can be in fact
empirically experientially reduced to
merely the value that we have for
somebody else to attain what it is that
they want you know an extreme example
would be cannibalism
the human being is reduced to just meet
for another another human being
count is saying there's something wrong
when that occurs that that's ignoring
something fundamental about us that
makes us different from other animals
other beings in the universe so he says
the human being must in all of his
actions whether they're directed to
himself or other rational beings must be
viewed always at the same time as an end
that must is a moral must it's not a
logical must it's not an empirical this
actually is the case he's saying this is
the way that we ought to actually see
other human beings and ourselves so he
says all the objects of inclination have
only a condition value for if there were
not those inclinations and the needs
granite of them their objects would be
valueless you know they provide us only
with certain hypothetical he says in
paradise beings whose existence depends
not on our will but on nature if they're
non rational beings have only a relative
value is means and are consequently
called called things so for example this
bread has value it's good nourishing
it's you know artisanal bread that I
made it has relative value it doesn't
have the value that a human being has
this book has relative value this tie
has relative dies this chalkboard has
relative value we could go on and on and
on and on
rational beings are called persons he
says because their nature already marks
them out as ends in themselves as
something which ought not to be used
merely as a means and consequently
imposes to that extent a limit on all
arbitrary treatment of them again is he
saying that it imposes this in an
empirical sense like you know I decide
hey I'm gonna use that person over there
and then like something pops up and you
know it says no no I can't do that you
know some sort of you know or around
them or something like that no this is
not something empirical this is
something rational if I'm actually
thinking straight and I say I'm gonna
use that person over there I'm just
gonna use them then something should be
sort of triggered in my my mind maybe
even at the level although count
wouldn't be the to you to happy with us
just at the level of you know feeling
saying yeah not what you ought to be
doing that's that's wrong that would be
a different kind of imposition of a
limit right so he says if there is to be
a supreme practical principle a
categorical imperative it must be such
that from the idea of something which is
necessarily an end for everyone because
it is end in itself it forms an
objective principle of the will it's
something that motivates us tells us not
only as individuals but as rational
beings among all other rational beings
that's what it means for it to be
objective it forms an objective
principles the will and consequently can
serve as a practical law what is the
ground of this principle he says
rational nature exists as an end in
itself rational nature exists as an end
not for other things not as a an end
that also happens to be a means for
something else but as an end in itself
final
final thing all right I can I can make
something like this and then for me I
can say I'm going to go I'm going to go
you know knock that person down so I can
have this business bit of bread and why
am I gonna have that bit of bread well
that that bread can then as an end at
one action can become a means for
another so I can satisfy my hunger or
you know if I'm kind of you know weird
so I can satisfy my perverse desire for
artisanal bread and then I can ask
myself further why in the hell do you
need to do that well you know the hunger
thing is pretty obvious so you can keep
the body alive satisfying hunger then
becomes a means what for another end and
we can go on and on and on with means
becoming further ends becoming further
means until we have to get to a point
where we say well this is the this is
the ultimate reason this is what's
really valuable for cons that's humanity
that's I should put this rational nature
that's has value that's what's at the
end of the entire chain events that's
what's at the limit so this categorical
imperative this formulation is going to
tell us how to do that let's look now
yet the actual categorical imperative
who says act in such a way that you
always treat humanity whether in your
own person or in the person of another
never simply as a means but always at
the same time as an S so let's break
this down there's four you may not see
it yet but there's four main things
you've got to pay close attention to
with this formulation so one is act in
such a way you always treat humanity
whether in your own person
or in the person of another this is
about the way in which you treat
humanity your rational nature your human
nature what it is for you to be able to
make laws for yourself to do right to do
wrong to choose right to choose wrong to
set yourself goals all those sorts of
things this is how you treat that in
your own person or in another so it's
not just about how you treat other
people a lot of times people want to
think that ethics is really just about
how you treat other people and you don't
have to worry about how you treat
yourself so there you know so long as
you're not hurting other people anything
you want to do is okay I would say there
are some things that when you're doing
them you are doing something wrong to
yourself even if you don't hurt anybody
else
you know I think hunt would for example
say taking illegal drugs you know the
fact that they're illegal you're
actually breaking a law and that's doing
something wrong and in one sense but if
you're taking drugs that are that are
you know doing something to to make you
well to put you in a state where you're
not yourself where you're reducing your
own rational capacities where over the
long term you're degrading your your own
talents and abilities maybe even your
own organic structure for those brain
damage if you're doing that sort of
thing Kant would stay even if you're not
hurting anybody else you are actually
doing something wrong to yourself and
now what would the actual wrongdoing me
well yeah act in such a way they treat
humanity whether in your own person or
in that of another never simply as a
means never just as a means
but always as and that so you shouldn't
just treat other people as a means you
also shouldn't treat yourself the as
amines or at least the humanity within
yourself as a mere means you should
always treat the other person as an as
having value as having what we call
human dignity
you should also treat yourself that way
that's what this categorical imperative
to say now I want to stress something
that what often gets overlooked in this
this is very very important
notice how this is Frank never simply as
a means so okay so that's saying a means
just by itself is off limit but always
at the same time as a net now ask
yourself this
are those mutually exclusive is it the
case that you're always either treating
somebody purely as a means or purely as
an end and never possibly as as both let
me give you an example where you are
actually treating a person as both a
means and as an ends I use this when I
teach my classroom students which makes
sense doesn't make quite as much sense
of the video when I'm teaching in the
classroom I'm getting paid to teach
those students right so I mean I'm
imparting knowledge or you know
cultivating learning or however you want
to frame it I am treating them to a
certain degree as a means a means
towards my income my sustenance my
survival whatever you like I might be
treating them as means in other ways too
the kind of professor gets off on being
the sage on the stage and I'm treating
them as a means for for the end of my
getting to feel like a big you know big
professor or something like that if I am
treating my students kind of meanly
because I enjoy being a sadist and
hurting people I'm using them as a means
as well right but let's just stick with
income now if I'm just making a buck off
of them and I'm not actually giving them
anything in return I'm clearly treating
them just as a means what if for their
money I give everybody an A and I also
do kind of a song and dance and
entertaining you know I should show a
lot of non class related videos and you
know get into a lot of disco well what
do you think about all this you know
just kind of make you feel good kind of
stuff I'm giving them something in
return right there so getting something
for their money I'm still just treating
them as a means cuz why am I getting
them all this this this you know
entertaining crap this you know
saccharine you know on nourishing mental
food so I can get something out of it
like peace of mind they don't report me
to the Dean or anything like that
what am I supposed to be giving them
student learning is supposed to be
taking place which means not just that
they memorize a bunch of things and get
them in their head that they actually
undergo some degree of transformation
some growth as a person at least in
their intellectual faculties if I'm
doing that then even though I am
treating them as a means I am also
treating them as an end because I'm
treating them as a rational nature which
has dignity and worth in itself and if
they've placed themselves in my hands
and I'm an educator then the goal the
the whole point of the process there is
for them to become edgy
so they are being treated as an end in
that case they're being treated as both
an end and as a means so it's possible
to treat somebody as both at the same
time the key is not to just treat them
as a means now another thing that we
gotta clarify another thing you got to
think about that I don't want to leave
you I don't want to end this video
without you actually having a clear
concept of is this how is it that you
can use yourself does that actually make
sense I mean if what it is to be an end
means the capacity to like give yourself
ends to make choices what we call
autonomy being able to decide for
yourself well then you know doesn't it
seem like anything that you want to do
would be a ok because you know you're
treating yourself isn't it and you're
giving yourself what you want well
here's the thing
conflict saying you got to look at the
nature of the human person what is it
that you're composed of you have your
rational nature right you have reason
and you have a free will and then you
got all these appetites desires and
clinicians and they want you to do
certain things and those things might
not actually be in your interest they
may not be in your in your long-term
interest they may not actually be good
for you on a higher level which has to
do with your rationality so for example
there are certain kinds of professions
that even though they might be very
lucrative and they might actually be fun
to engage in they would be morally
degrading for you to to pursue at least
from the conscient perspective right and
if you in fact follow that sort of
course you would be treating humanity in
your person as a means to the end of
making money and having
a time you would be treating the better
part of yourself as a mere means to an
end satisfying the less good parts of
yourself the less worthwhile parts of
yourself so there are ways in which you
can in fact treat yourself treat a part
of yourself as a means to the end for
another part of yourself and kaan would
say if that part of yourself that you're
making the end is merely these
subjective preferences and desires and
not something like you know I'm gonna
cultivate myself so I can actually be a
good person and I can do what I'm
supposed to do and I can know what my
duty is and do it if you're doing that
you're treating yourself as a means to
an end there's other ways in which you
could by the way in which you connect
yourself up in relationships with other
people treat yourself as a mere means to
an end as well for instance to be a
flatterer to be a toady
you know is to try to get something out
of somebody else to be a kiss you know a
kiss butter right a yes-man or yes
moment or something like that Khan would
say that's that's actually morally
degrading and it seems like you're also
treating the other person Zamir means -
that - right so there's a problem with
that but you are lowering yourself to
treat yourself as a means to that other
person's ends because you know why do
people like flatterers around because
they make them feel good and you're also
treating yourself as a means to the end
of whatever it is that you want to get
out of flattering that person being
invited to the great parties or you know
making some some money having money
tossed at you or getting prestige or
something like that those are lesser
values those are not the sort of thing
that context a rational being should
place high up and so you would be
treating yourself again as
means tonight so to bring this to a
close what have we got here we've got
formulation of the categorical
imperative that basically says don't use
people but now we've specified the way
in which we're talking about this when
we talk about don't use people we don't
just mean don't use other people don't
use yourself and by use we mean you know
it's a treat just as a means not
treating as an ad not as something that
actually has dignity the capacity to
choose to set goals for oneself the set
ends for oneself